he gave the two little guys 30 minutes
locks and 45 minutes optimization from
Isolde because the last difficult
section is going to tell us what
dispatch all right thank you very much
for the invitation to speak in the
session um this is somewhat daunting
given the list of other speakers but I
hope I have something interesting to say
so the one thing is the talk is very
different from the previous talks in
particular I'd I'll actually go back
much more into the theory of what
ride-sharing systems and how I think the
theory of ride-sharing systems works and
what are sort of the interesting
theoretical questions so kind of hang it
back in more with what's the aim of the
Simon's workshops in general and this is
so I'll present two pieces of work which
were done with a set of amazing
collaborators so Daniel France sitting
somewhere in the back of the room he's
currently on I'm standing at the back of
the room okay he's currently at Cornell
but he's soon heading to MIT by way of
lift to Doris Lycoris we saw his picture
yesterday if you attended I was stuck
he's supposed to be here but he's
exploring the life of being a traveling
researcher I think he was last spotted
in Chicago or something like that so
that sort of work which I briefly talked
about for those of you attended the boot
camp workshop but I kind of summarized
it again because there's some people
here who I'd love to tell this work who
I'd love to describe this work to but
the main focus of this talk is going to
be on some work we've been doing more
recently and this is joint work with
pangyo Chen and Yosh canarias who are
both in the Columbia Business School so
without further ado what's the dispatch
problem so this is kind of highly
stylized problem that I'm going to focus
on for the entirety of this talk so what
the problem the problem is as follows
you show up in 4th Street Station you
want to get a lift you sort of request a
ride the platform knows that there are
five of these cars waiting around and it
needs to decide which car to match to
you they're all sort of the same
distance away it's not going to affect
you in terms of time but perhaps it
affects the system in some larger sense
over time and the question we want to
ask is
how should we make this decision and how
does this affect the missed requests in
the future and given my background I'm
going to try and model this as a some
sort of stochastic decision-making
problem so in particular here's the
model that I will be considering this is
the same thing I presented in the
bootcamp talk so essentially I'm
thinking of the system as being
comprised of a fixed number of stations
as think of these as localities in the
network so here we have n stations these
big circles and there are K cars or call
them units which are scattered across
these stations and at any time the state
of the system is where these cars are
located so for each station how many
cars are located at that station the
identity of the car doesn't matter and
I'm going to assume that there's a
stream of passengers who are arriving at
station I wanting to go to station J and
they are arriving according to a Poisson
process with rate CIJ so what happens if
this passenger shows up well the
passenger requests are right if the
price is reasonable they get much to an
idle unit they get into the car the car
starts driving towards the destination
this perhaps this usually takes some
travel time we are going to assume it's
independent and actually for this stock
to keep things really simple we'll
assume all the trip times are zero some
of the results carry over with this some
require this and I've mentioned that as
I go along okay so what happens if
someone comes and sees that a unit is
not available - what if you come and see
there are no cars we're in your
neighborhood well the assumption I'm
going to make is that the customers
myopic they have some other option
perhaps they could use this thing called
uber and so what they'll do is they will
just leave the system and what I want to
do is I want to minimize the long-term
average rate at which I miss this
request so someone showed up at lyft
they really wanted to take a lift we
didn't have a car to offer and
throughout this talk again to keep
things simple I'm going to assume that
the prices are fixed I am only focusing
on the dispatch problem so what's the
dispatch problem well I didn't really
need
to lose this guy the reason I'm thinking
that this person is not going to take
the lift is because there's no car
available in that immediate neighborhood
but maybe as Garrett was mentioning
maybe the person's a little more patient
and maybe I could offer him a car from a
neighbor a neighboring neighborhood so
somewhere close by such that the time it
takes for that car to show up is not too
high and the others have big assumption
our main throw this talk is that this is
essentially for free so what I mean by
that is the set of localities which are
close enough such that if you send a car
from there for the passenger it's as if
you send it from the same neighborhood
this is clearly not true some things
again extend without this assumption
some things don't but it's sort of a
very interesting simplification one can
make which gives very interesting
insights into the problem okay so that's
the setting and I'm guessing at this
point most of us are looking at this and
thinking okay I've seen this problem
before in one form or the other or
you're thinking okay clearly this model
is inadequate it's like not capturing
many things so so before I go there let
me kind of set up this model in a
slightly different way so this is what
I'm calling the bipartite matching with
externalities problems so the idea is
here again we have three stations and
what I've shown here is which station
can call vehicles from which other
station so every station can use
vehicles which are located in that
station itself but two can kind of
summon vehicles from three three perhaps
can someone from two maybe there's a
high speed or a one-way road from three
to two and so you can't go the other way
and similarly one can summon from two
but not vice versa
so that's what that graph represents and
what I'm doing is I'm kind of converting
it into a bipartite graph where I'm
saying that I have the same stations
drawn on both sides now on one side you
have supplies so these are the cars
which are waiting at each of these
stations on the other side you have
passengers who are showing up to make
ride requests and the graph is encoding
where can you pull supply from for free
and just a bit of notation so the
lambdas are I'm going to suppose we
never lost a write the lambda
essentially represents the total amount
of passengers who are showing up at
Station three so I'm just adding up over
everyone who wants to show up at a
station and similarly Miu is the total
number of passengers who show up at the
station looking for her right so these
are sort of people showing up at the
destination these are people showing up
at the source
so the problem as is looks exactly like
bipartite matching with this interesting
sort of twist that when you serve
someone and that person goes to the
destination then yourself changing the
supplier at the destination so that's
the notion of the externality that I
have in the title and if you think a
little about it
it's clear that if I just ignored all
this like poor son and all the
stochastic business um I have to have
that for every station the total supply
available for it is more than the demand
which shows up like that's a minimum
requirement in order to be able to serve
everyone that has to be true otherwise
so a basic health condition would say
that you can't do anything and in some
sense what this talk is about is okay
how do we actually come up with policies
which handle the stochastic fluctuations
so so that's the entire model that's
what I'm gonna sort of focus on for the
rest of the talk transit times
throughout yeah so so it's okay
I mean many of you should have a lot of
questions at this point it shouldn't be
satisfied there are many things missing
in the model and so so little intimate
so why this model right why should I
even care about this really simple
problem so so this is a picture which I
actually first saw in this beautiful
book by Jason hotline on mechanism
design it's actually a sketch by Picasso
looking at bulls and he's what because I
was doing is because we're sort of
starting off with a bull and then kind
of deconstructing the boolean different
forms that's a kind of giving lesser and
lesser information reducing extraneous
details etc and the way I sort of think
of this as in some sense all of the
sketches are beautiful ok it's not that
any one sketch is the true sketch of the
bull there is something interesting
going on in each of these sketches and
to me at least that's actually true for
any model for a real system all models
are inaccurate I mean you can never
capture a model incomplete details
and what's really more important for me
is what's the question that drives the
model and is your sort of model
correctly matching up with what you want
to answer so what what do I want to
answer these are sort of some of the
things that I'm hoping to get to in this
talk so so what is the correct structure
of dispatch policies if you have if
you're running this lyft or uber
dispatch system um what should you be
worried about when you serve designed
these policies what's the value of
actually doing real-time dispatch is it
okay to not do it in real-time can you
have something pre-programmed versus
real-time what's the role of information
in the system how does it matter how
does it matter how accurate it is so
should you hire one more data scientist
or should you be hiring queuing
theorists and sort of a very meta level
question I'm kind of ignoring pricing
throughout but it's that even fair and
this is actually a really deep question
which I think all right sharing forms
kind of struggle with to some extent I
mean is it there's a sense in which
pricing and dispatch are coupled
together and that just makes life really
difficult is it fine to ignore like
decouple the two or others are
fundamental couplings between the two so
that's this kind of question I want to
get to and the way I think of it we are
really in this kind of also this for me
is of the economic models or the CS
theory the case of the models which are
very very sparsely specified as one or
two parameters to define the whole thing
this is kind of closer to like the
simulation models if you also some with
our stock yesterday these are like
really complicated beautiful
visualization things moving around but
it's unclear if you can answer questions
of this sort in a model like that for me
that over there is really the kind of
thing Alex was talking about like real
systems slightly abstracted and then
trying to do something interesting with
it whereas the world I live in the surf
world of stochastic control and mod
models which like stochastic assumption
this kind of over here there are many
more gradations but but that's the
picture and that one's kind of beautiful
so yeah let's focus on that
why else would I want to why else do I
think the stock is interesting um in
some sense if you don't even believe
anything I say in terms of ride-sharing
and many people don't and that's fine I
think it's sort of nice that there are
these really deep connections between
these really fundamental problems in
ride-sharing and wait
questions and algorithms and control so
these are two recent theoretical
advances which I found were truly
amazing so one was this whole line of
work on the optimal control of input
switches by she can say with a gemma
Gallery Buena who's somewhere here and
secondly this there's this sort of
long-standing conjecture about thinking
about the online case of a problem and
there's been some amazing advances made
in this actually in both these problems
they were both open for something like
20 to 30 years and in both these
problems we have had recent advances
which kind of took everyone by surprise
unfortunately the problem I was looking
at was not considered open somehow
people hadn't thought about it but what
I'll try to convince you in the
remaining time that I have is we think
it is in some sense reached a fairly
satisfying closure
that's the implementer so back to like
so what's the main question that we are
looking at and what do we do in this
problem okay so this is again the main
question so we had these n stations K
units Poisson arrivals there's some
assumptions to just make sure this
problem is not trivial you can't just
pull a car from anywhere that you feel
like this some there's some tension in
the graph and and you need things to be
reducible you can take care of stuff
like that but just let's assume we have
that and we're given this bipartite
compatibility graph which tells us back
and we pull supply from for free and
what we want to understand is how do we
come up with a dispatch rule so how do
we come up with a rule which maps the
current state to a rule to deciding who
should serve whom which maximizes the
rate at which we can actually serve the
people coming in in the steady state
induced by this dispatch rule so it's a
little complicated because the the
dispatch rule is looking at the state to
do something and then we are letting it
run and eventually this is a finite
state Markov chains it is going to reach
a stationary distribution and in that
stationary distribution I want to
understand how well we are performing
why can this be tricky well one obvious
thing is that the state space is
exponential and so the policy space is
also exponential we are allowing the
policies to look at the state at any
time and decide what to do so that that
sort of the typical the curse of
dimensionality a slightly more a hidden
and more subtle thing in this problem is
that this problem is non convex even in
very very simple settings so even if you
have state independent dispatch rules
and I think one vehicle and two stations
that's like the least we got it down to
beyond that it's revealed but even in
the case like that this problem is non
convex so if you try doing any sort of
standard thing by just running gradient
descent maybe it'll work but they're no
guarantees that it should yep yes I'm
sort of skipping things a bit so Chi IJ
is the it's an indicator that if a guy
shows up at I under this dispatch rule
queue he is actually being served in
state X of packing all of that into
should take a slightly impressionistic
view of it it's this is the steady state
rate at which people are being served
I guess it's not a question okay so
that's kind of what's tricky about this
problem and and perhaps that's the sense
in which this is why it wasn't even
considered an open problem and didn't
really seem like there was anything
tractable that you could do in this
setting and so it was a great delight
for us when we figured out you could do
something tractable so the first work
that we did this is work with Daniel and
odorous where we basically showed that
there's a way of getting a state
independent dispatch policy so I'm not
even going to look at who is there where
the vehicles are located and this this
comes out of a flow relaxation so it's
actually a pretty easy to compute
policy but you can give very very good
guarantees for it so in particular you
can show that the policy is within a 1
plus n over K factor I'm sort of like
making everything positive or greater
than one so it's within 1 plus n over K
if you have instantaneous trips
this is actually an exact bomb like
there's no hidden constants anywhere
which travel times the bound gets a
little Messier you can again compute it
exactly but what you can choose in the
worst case it's one plus order 1 over
square root K so so he's n was the
number of stations K is the number of
variables so I'm always in I'm thinking
of a world which is somewhat dense there
are more vehicles than stations not come
to that but this is what I was talking
about in my the bootcamp so I
essentially will ignore some of the
fluctuations and construct an
optimization problem which turns out to
give these casualties so now I'll
briefly mention it back to you so but
yes I'll go over this quickly because
this was work I talked about before but
so the interesting thing about this work
is it's actually extremely general so
even though I'm talking about the
dispatch problem it actually works if
you want to think about pricing if you
want to think about actually taking
driverless vehicles and rebalancing them
it works for revenue it works for
welfare it works if you want to do
fancier stuff than that um it's it's
just a very very nice general technique
for solving any of these close control
problems and it also gives what's called
large supply
large market optimality so these are
kind of much more specialized tools and
probability which people have developed
for studying these problems and in some
sense we are just circumventing all
these specialized tools and kind of
showing all of this in an elementary way
so it was really pleasing to get these
results um the problem was that we are
kind of stuck at this one over K or 1
over square root K rates and we were
wondering okay can you do better and and
what we managed to show more recently in
this work which we just sort of finished
writing and this work with the edge
canarian from you Chan is that there
actually you can do better if you stated
dependent dispatch policy then in
particular we can give you a family of
state dependent dispatch policies which
all get you exponential decay in this
the rate of which rate the sub
optimality and you can't exactly nail
the pre constants but if you are just
interested in the optimal exponent you
can find that using a convex program and
so that's going to be the main focus of
the talk today any questions about the
results or just what they mean I'm gonna
serve briefly go over the previous
argument because that comes in to a
small extent in the new work so the way
we constructed this state independent
policies was by this this flow
relaxation um and this is something we
call the elevated flow relaxation and
the basic idea is that you kind of relax
this so we have this really complicated
objective with all sorts of like
probabilities but nobody kind of relaxed
this into a flow program so you just
optimize over the fraction of I to J
requests that you accept in steady-state
we don't know what this is but like how
to achieve this but let's just optimize
over that and we only encode sort of
essential conservation laws things which
can be encoded as flow so things like
flow balance and literal so actually
these are the only two that we encode
this doesn't make sense not too
important you can go back and see the
bootcamp video but sort of what we then
do is we take this program and we show
that it is tight if the number of
vehicles goes to infinity so if you keep
on keep everything constant and set the
number of vehicles to infinity any
policy in this floor area or any of
these flow relaxation any point in this
poly tope can be achieved by some policy
in this space
we know what the policy is and then we
do the self interesting thing that we
take the infinite policy and kind of
pull it back to a finite system the way
we did that and I'm being a little
indulgent here but um I kind of really
like this professor essentially we
construct this as a sequence of product
from chains and somehow bound these
normalization constants so this is kind
of work stemming from like the seminal
work of Frank Kelly long back in the 80s
and it's unfortunate he's not here but
it's kind of a interesting use of the
techniques that he had developed back
then and sort of combining these we get
this result that the objective in the K
unit system if we use the infinite unit
policies is within this cape over K plus
n of the objective in the of the optimal
solution in the K unit system although
we have no idea what the solution is the
somewhat impressionistic
we can blame it on Aleks for less time
but I'm going to actually move on to the
next part the main takeaways again being
that we have this of new technique of
getting the state independent controls
and the two big problems being that the
way we actually find these controls that
we really need to know the demand rate
and the price price elasticities and
these guarantees actually tight we
cannot do better than what we've shown
over you you know surf counter examples
so what I want to talk about is how do
we go beyond this so again to try to
even understand how to go beyond this I
need to go back to this original
problems I have this bipartite graph I'm
trying to decide who gets much to whom
and I know that all these servers kind
of like rebar or they keep moving based
on how we match them up so we have these
flows of servers and of demand and a
slightly different way of looking at
exactly the same system is actually to
look at the fraction of servers who are
located at each location and now what
you're doing is once you normalize this
you're actually sort of embedding this
entire space in the simplex so you're
taking these the state space and then
sort of putting it as a you're plotting
a point in this K dimensional simplex
all right sorry the N dimensional
simplex and in some sense what the
system is doing about the system plus
the control is doing is it
doing a random work in the simplex the
problem happens as long as you're in the
interior of the simplex you're fine
there's always some vehicle available
for you to match up the problem happens
when you're sort of hitting the
boundaries so the point at which you hit
the boundary is then all bets are off
maybe someone comes in and asks you
exactly for the vehicle which you don't
have and so what we really want to do is
okay we have this random work going
around in the simplex can we sort of
change the controls to make sure it
stays in the interior as long as
possible and this formal way of thinking
about this is instead of a it's kind of
hopeless to analyze the process exactly
or at least I don't know how to do it
but what we do is we kind of scale the
number of vehicles to infinity and then
we look at what's called a large
deviation exponent so we are trying to
target an exponential decay in the
fraction of drop requests what I'm going
to do is I'll repair ammeter eyes the
system to just look at exactly this
quantity what is the coefficient of that
fraction is it greater than zero am I
even getting a exponential decay or not
for those of you seen large deviations
is exactly the rate function of this
with respect to K but if you've not seen
this kind of treatment just think of it
as we know we're trying to get an
exponential decay so let's sort of zoom
into the the exponent and try to see how
good it is
now what I said earlier was that the
policies that we had for state
independent control were type it
actually turns out that they are tight
in a much sort of wider set of policies
and the crucial thing that lets us get
out of these sort of non exponential
decay is this assumption so what is this
assumption so this is something called
complete resource pooling and queuing
but essentially if you have ever seen
halls condition this is exactly halls
condition except with the strict
inequality instead of greater than equal
to and you could ask okay is this really
necessary do we really need halls
conditions on instead of looking at
halls condition in this graph with a
strict inequality and well it's clear
that the greater than equal to is
essential because if that's not true
just by halls theorem you must be
dropping demand but what it turns out is
that the strict inequality is actually
essential so in particularly if this
held with equality we have a proposition
which shows that you cannot get
exponential decay so the only hope of
getting any sort of exponential decay is
that you actually have the strict halls
inequality five minutes so the main
result that I'm self trying to go to
I'll try to build up to is the fact that
as long as you have this condition you
can actually always get exponential
decay and in fact you can get the
optimal exponential decay under the
serve stricter health condition and one
way of thinking about what the policy is
is to kind of think of a strawman policy
so this is the most natural greedy
policy that you think of if you were
designing the system it's in queueing
this is called max weight and the idea
is whenever let's say someone shows up
at one you look at all the compatible
Q's and you say okay this guy has so
many cars this guy has so many cars well
he seems to have more cars let me pull a
car from there it's a very very natural
like local greedy policy which has this
amazing property that in many queuing
networks in particular any open queuing
network where like things come in and go
out it's actually known to be optimal in
sort of a strong sense
this was the result that Shrikant and
she with age approved laughter but
there's a long line of work by Sean and
others before that until natural
questions like how does max weight do in
this case and it's actually not
difficult to see it's suboptimal no if
you just think of the car demand coming
in at one a car at two can serve both
one and two a car at one can only serve
once it's sort of strictly dominated so
you'd rather use up this research before
using of this you can kind of exchange
the two does that make sense so so
there's no reason to actually use two
but max weight would say well they're
more cars they're you should use it so
this cannot be optimal and the thought
is okay can we somehow patch this
together and try to get something
optimal so here's sort of a natural
extension of max weight which is okay
greedy doesn't work what about scaled
greedy so what if I sort of have a
weight for each of these kills and then
do greedy with the serve linear scaling
and this is what we call the scaled max
weight policy and the idea is exactly
the same but except that instead of
pulling from the maximum Q I pull from
the maximum Q divided by this weight and
now you can see that if the weight for
one goes to zero I will never actually
pull from this Q you need or rather I'll
always pull from this Q the way it goes
to zero no matter how many cars are
there so so it's a much wider class of
policy than kind of the question is how
does this perform and the main result
that we have is that this class of
policies is actually optimal so there
exists a way of choosing these bits in
particularly the way to choose the
weights is from this horrible-looking
optimization problem but if you choose
the weights according to this this
policy is optimal for the rate function
now what is this thing
don't try to parse it but the main thing
is everything is positive we remember we
want it to be positive to get
exponential decay so everything here is
positive the only way this is positive
is the numerator is bigger than the
denominator and the numerator is sort of
the total flow coming into the cut
whereas the denominator is the total
flow going out of a cut so essentially
what we are saying is the rate function
or like the ability to get an
exponential decay is kind of connected
to a min cut problem in this graph but a
sort of a con
get admin got problem with all these
bizarre logs and this is tight so what
you can actually show is a converse
result where you can show that any
policy any state dependent policy cannot
achieve better than a certain rate so in
a very very strong sense there exists a
weight which is tight for this problem
there exists a weighted max weight
policy which is tight we solve this
problem yeah but I'll give you a little
bit of intuition so yeah so so here's
some intuition how to choose the face I
mean this is really abstractors sort of
I wonder now convince you it's actually
useful it turns out that the way to
choose the weights really depends on the
information structure it depends on how
much information you have about the
entire system in order to actually solve
that optimization problem so if you had
no information what you would do is you
would you could choose all the weights
to be equal in which case you get
exactly the max weight policy and one
sort of offshoot of our result is that
max weight does give you exponential
decay except that the rate function is
not optimal so the coefficient is not
optimal but it's off by at most a factor
of n on the other hand if you knew all
everything perfectly and you were really
brave to try and solve this problem you
could find something which had the
optimal decay for this problem but in
some sense I and this is what I think is
much more interesting this is kind of
what we are trying to think about now
what if you had partial information so
in the problem really captures this
notion that in in ridesharing that these
are cuts which are very critical so
there are cuts where there's more drain
from one end versus the other and you
need to somehow protect those cuts and
this like if you could parse through
what we wrote it essentially captures
exactly this notion how do we protect
all cuts simultaneously in the network
there's another really interesting thing
which we kind of observed right now
which is that um there's a sense in
which the the theorem actually implies
that there's a separation of pricing and
discuss so what we're saying is once you
fix the pricing you can get an
exponential decay in you can basically
serve everyone with very very with
exponential one minus e to the minus
in probability so in some sense you
could have done the pricing just based
on the flow problems and then done
dispatch in real time and at least in
theory that should be enough unclear if
this holds in practice but it's it's at
least it's interesting that we can say
something of that sort okay so I'm gonna
skip the proof so it's it's technically
messy there fancy-looking Lyapunov
function so you have to use a Lyapunov
function on the simplex using some
interesting tools but sort of just to
leave you with like what what we did and
what I think is interesting so this has
been kind of a long line of work
thinking about these problems and we we
feel now we have a really good
understanding of what it means to design
good policies for these problems so what
it means to design good state
independent policies using flow
relaxations and what it means to design
good real-time policies using these sort
of scale max weight ideas but they're
sort of a bunch there's a huge number of
things which we don't know so we don't
everything the second half of the talk
using scale max weight we didn't
actually use travel times we know if
travel times show up things change at
least in the extreme case you cannot do
better than one over square root K but
what is the scaling if you have travel
times thrown in now the proof of the
last part was really really heavy
machinery we are using these like
Lyapunov functions and large deviations
I strongly feel that there should be an
elementary proof of this fact that you
can get exponential decay but okay
Elementary in quotes and this is
something we've been thinking a bit
about we have some ideas but doesn't
seem an easy thing to solve how do we
adapt the information how do we adopt
policies to information structures what
sort of the banded version of thinking
about these problems something which I
know David's been thinking a lot about
how do you sort of patch together
dispatch when you do write pooling this
is we are only assuming a single right
but what happens if you can do multiple
right so the lot of stuff interesting
open questions I'm hoping I've convinced
you there's interesting theory to do so
even if this even if you're not working
at lyft and uber and you can't talk
about what you do there's still sort of
interesting problems that you can just
kind of sit back and think about and
yeah thank you very much
[Applause]
so like it's sort of about sort of
scheduling the way you get feedback from
the jobs that you serve so one thing to
say it's the what math way is a magnetic
stable when you have networks so there's
where the feedbacks we know and there is
nothing close except yeah I mean I think
no no cute systems where you can inject
customers and then pull them out so
they're sort of meant to be like a
silicon manufacturing example you can do
back metric for that and then this is
abducting off to some terms you add them
because it means I could imagine that
could apply in this type of model and
then we should definitely feed buckets
weighted max weight where you divide by
the traffic intensity back pressure and
the wayfinder yeah okay am i claiming
this is unbelievably surprising no but I
do think it's okay it was fairly
non-trivial to show this works and
partly what really what's really
irritating in this whole system is
because it's closed you kind of don't
have directions in which to go out so
there's no state space collapse in
certain sense so I'm assuming you can't
wait too much yeah we should take this
off
[Applause]